Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today you are going to see virtual
worlds like you’ve never seen before!
This is done with something that we call
NERFs. So, what are NERFs? Essentially,
we grab a smartphone and a set of images go in,
and reality comes out. When there is a gap between
the images, it can synthesize all this information
and it almost looks like reality. Absolute magic.
Now, many of these are neural network-based
techniques and take quite a while to compute.
However, later NVIDIA published a technique
by the name instant NERFs. As the name says,
this trains incredibly quickly and is one of
the best techniques in its class. And today,
these can be produced from a smartphone camera,
and can be generated in a matter of seconds.
But, there is a problem. Do you see the
problem? Well, let me ask you another
question - how do you spot a Fellow Scholar
who watches Two Minute Papers? Well, of course,
they are always looking at thin structures. Why?
Well, look! So, instant NERFs are super fast,
but have trouble with thin structures. And
now, hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
and let’s look at how this new paper deals with
the same problem. Oh my, that is outstanding!
But wait, it is only better on thin structures,
or is it generally better than this
previous technique? Well, let’s see. Yes,
thin structures are still present, but the
new one is significantly better in terms
of quality. Wow. And this is just one year and
one more paper down the line. Very impressive.
Also, here is a comparison against Mip-NERF, this
is real good, so I bet the new one isn’t better,
especially that this previous one ran
for about 20 times longer. Let’s see.
Is that really possible? The new one
is still better. 20 times faster,
and we don’t even have to pay for it by
giving up quality. This is still better.
With this, we can now just grab a smartphone
and scan a real place and make a virtual
world out of it. This can be used for a video
games, videoconferencing, animation movies,
you name it. Now, not even this work is perfect,
you see, specular reflections like this display
are not that faithful to reality, and if we look
at severely undersampled regions, this can happen.
However, just think about the fact that all
this came just one more paper down the line.
Now combine this together with this amazing
light transport paper that can take photos
of real-world objects and create a super
advanced, digital material model with just
the right physical parameters to replicate it.
So, NERFs can help with the geometry, and light
transport can help with the materials. And a
potential combination of the two could create
even more incredible virtual worlds and games for
us in the near future. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!